This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“绝对真人。2%。”这就是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己破茧重生。收听《2%》。记住是数字2. percent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播卡尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方说其实都不太安全，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“欧恩斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次检测。”这需要一大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for. our psychology.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。“我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。”我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜们。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，在这里我们探讨20多岁时最大的改变、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. Today, we have a special edition episode. We have my yearly birthday episode. Last year, I think last year we spoke about birthday anxiety and the year before it was like the fear of getting older maybe.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴能有你们在这里。今天，我们有一期特别节目。我们迎来我的年度生日特辑。去年，我想去年我们谈论了生日焦虑，再前一年可能是对变老的恐惧之类的话题。
But today we're doing something more classic. And I'm going to talk about the 26 lessons I've learned from the last 26 years of life. Some of these are really practical, others are more psychological, some are really personal, some are just weird. But I went out for dinner with myself the other night and I sat down, I brought my little notebook and I just really reflected on what I've learned. And it was rather emotional. Like, it was, I did have a few tears of the waiters were looking at me weird. I also did have a few martini. So two of those things could have contributed to each other. but this last year has just been so mind-blowing.
但今天我们要聊点更经典的内容。我将分享我从过去26年的人生中学到的26个教训。其中一些非常实用，另一些则更具心理学意义，有些非常私人，有些只是奇奇怪怪。但前几天我和自己出去吃晚餐，我坐下来，带上了我的小笔记本，真正反思了我所学到的东西。而且过程相当感人。真的，我确实掉了几滴眼泪，服务员看我的眼神都怪怪的。我也喝了几杯马提尼。所以这两件事可能相互促进了。但过去这一年实在是太震撼了。
It's just been the biggest year of my life. My book came out, the podcast on Netflix, moving to London. Those are just the headlines. And it's like kind of hard to process sometimes. And I'm so grateful and I was just really reflecting on the lessons that I've gained, both in the last year, but before any of this happened, before I was even in my 20s when I was 17, 16, yeah, 21, things that have stopped me as well from from all those experiences and it was actually really
这简直是我人生中最重要的一年。我的书出版了，播客上了Netflix，搬到了伦敦。这些还只是大事件。有时甚至很难去消化。我心怀感激，我一直在反思我获得的教训，不仅是在过去这一年里，还有在这一切发生之前，甚至在我20岁之前，当我17岁、16岁时，是的，还有21岁，那些经历也同样造就了现在的我，而且实际上真的……
therapeutic to just like sit down and put them on a page so if you have a birthday coming up I would actually really really encourage you to do this and just to reflect on the lesson one lesson from every year from the past however many years of your life it can get pretty emotional but I want to share them with you guys today so without further ado let's get into it okay let's begin with lesson number one. Lesson number one, this is the most important one, I think. Every year you will realize more and more how young you actually are. I remember turning 20 and being like, it is the beginning of the end for me, which is ridiculous.
坐下来把它们写在纸上是非常有治疗效果的。所以如果你即将迎来生日，我真的、真的非常鼓励你这样做，去反思从过去无论多少岁的人生中每年学到的一个教训。这可能会变得相当情绪化，但我今天想跟你们分享这些。所以废话不多说，我们切入正题吧。好的，让我们从第一课开始。第一课，我认为这是最重要的一课。每年你都会越来越深刻地意识到自己其实有多年轻。我记得20岁的时候觉得，这对我来说是末日的开始，这简直太荒谬了。
It's ludicrous. Like, I'd only been an adult for like two years at that point. But it just felt like time was already starting to crush me and move very full. fast. And, you know, then 21 came around. I felt the same way. Then 22, 23, and I felt a little bit less. And it's become a little bit less intense. It was definitely still there last year. But now at 26, I feel so young. I feel my age. And I feel my youth so clearly. And I also know I just guess based on experience, it just keeps getting better and it keeps getting different. I've also stopped joking with my friends that I'm still 22. I used to do that and I was like, you know what?
太荒唐了。就好像，到那个时候我才当了两年成年人而已。但当时感觉时间已经开始压垮我，并且过得非常快。然后，你知道的，21岁来了。我也有同感。接着是22岁、23岁，这种感觉稍微少了一点。这种压迫感变得不那么强烈了。去年肯定还是有的。但现在26岁了，我感觉自己好年轻。我能清晰地感受到自己的年龄。我也清晰地感受到了自己的青春。而且我也知道，凭直觉和经验，生活只会越来越好，也会变得越来越丰富多彩。我也不再和朋友开玩笑说我还22岁了。我以前常那样，然后我想：“你知道吗？”
No, I'm excited about aging. You know, that term youth is wasted on the young? I think that's what they're referring to here. Like, honestly, when you're young, you obsess over not being the age you were the year before and we obsess over getting older, not realizing how much time we're wasting in the prime of our lives thinking about aging. We think 30 years old and we think 50 years old and we think 50 or 60 years old when those are prime years. Like we've got so much to look forward to. And that has been a huge blessing from my 26th year. Like I feel my age and my age is young. Whatever my fears and whatever the fearmongering of society wants to tell me that I'm, I'm like seconds from death is like ridiculous. And I think that's been a very important lesson. Secondly, it is impossible to waste time.
不，我对变老感到兴奋。你知道“青春往往浪费在年轻人身上”那句话吗？我想这正是他们在这里所指的。老实说，当你年轻的时候，你痴迷于自己不再是去年的那个年纪，我们痴迷于变老，却没有意识到我们把多少时间浪费在了思考变老上，而这些本该是我们生命中的黄金时期。我们想到30岁，想到50岁，想到50岁或60岁，而那些其实是黄金时期。我们还有那么多值得期待的事情。这成为了我26岁这一年的一大福祉。我能感受到我的年龄，而我的年龄还很年轻。无论我的恐惧是什么，无论社会制造的恐慌想要告诉我，我离死亡只有几秒钟，这都太荒谬了。我认为这是一个非常重要的教训。其次，浪费时间是不可能的。
I don't know where this idea came from of like, I'm wasting my 20s. I'm wasting my time. It's like disappearing from right underneath me. Let's be clear here. Time is not something you can spoil. It's not something you can misuse. Like it's not a bag of spinach that you left in the back of the fridge. As long as you are having an experience, every moment is contributing to your story.
我不知道“我在浪费20多岁的时光”、“我在浪费时间”这种想法是从哪儿来的。感觉它就在我眼皮底下消逝。我们要搞清楚一件事。时间不是你可以糟蹋的东西。它不是你可以误用的东西。它不像是被你忘在冰箱角落里的一袋菠菜。只要你还在经历着什么，每一个时刻都在为你的故事添砖加瓦。
Even the time that you spent waiting and the time that you feel like life isn't moving fast enough. Time is a human construct. We have to remember. There are days that feel like years and there are years that feel like days and days where life is completely going to change all at once and it's just going to feel like everything has just happened in that moment. And I used to get so panicked that I wasn't allocating my time well enough. And obviously a big part of that was like a deep fear of regret as well that I was missing out. But now I know that as long as I'm doing something, anything with my life, even if other people don't understand it or see the meaning in it, time is being well spent. And those experiences in themselves, even if they're not exactly
甚至连你用来等待的时间，以及你觉得生活进展不够快的时间也是如此。时间是一个人类构建的概念。我们必须记住这一点。有些日子感觉像过年一样漫长，有些年份感觉像过日一样短暂，还有些日子生活会瞬间发生彻底的改变，感觉一切都在那一刻发生了。我过去常常因为没有把时间分配得足够好而惊慌失措。显然，其中很大一部分原因是对错失的深深恐惧，担心自己错过了什么。但现在我知道，只要我在生活中做着某事、任何事，即使其他人不理解或看不到其中的意义，时间也没有被白白浪费。这些经历本身，即使它们不完全是……
the ones I want to be having, they are really, really valuable. Okay, let's do a little trifecta of lessons here, a three for one deal. Fight with your friends, forgive your friends. We recognize that sometimes you are the asshole. Let's start with number one. Fight with your friends. I said this in our is friendship meant to be an inconvenient episode, but you deserve friends who are willing to fight with you and to really like get it all out in the open with you. Friends are people that you have no reason to fight with. Good friends are those you want to avoid fighting with. Best friends, great friends are those that you will go toe to toe with. That is
我想要经历的那些，也真的是非常、非常有价值的。好了，我们来做一个三合一的教训组合，买三赠一的优惠。和你的朋友吵架，原谅你的朋友。承认有时你就是个混蛋。让我们从第一点开始。和你的朋友吵架。我在“友谊注定是一段不方便的关系吗”那一期里说过，你值得拥有那些愿意和你吵架、真正愿意跟你开诚布公的朋友。朋友是那些你没有理由跟他们吵架的人。好朋友是那些你尽量避免与他们发生争执的人。最好的朋友、伟大的朋友是那些敢于和你针锋相对的人。那是……
how you know that they're on that next level. Conflict is uncomfortable. It's not as uncomfortable as losing somebody and not being able to have them in your life in the future. Part of that is also number two, forgive your friends, right? Obviously there is
你如何知道他们达到了那个更高的层次。冲突是让人不舒服的。但它没有失去某个人、以后生命里再也没有他们那么让人不舒服。这其中一部分也对应了第二点，原谅你的朋友，对吧？显然，在某种程度上……
a level where you probably can't, but I lost a lot of friends in my early 20s over stupid mistakes that I couldn't forgive people for and I would have made those same mistakes as well. And I regret it all the time. I wish I'd had the foresight to realize, like, wow, that was really small and minuscule. And those problems, like, that's nothing. But the damage had already been done, yeah, by them, but also by me, because I couldn't forgive. And I didn't feel like I could go back and say, hey, maybe I was wrong because I was so, like, headstrong in my
可能在某种程度上你无法做到，但在我20岁出头的时候，我因为一些愚蠢的错误失去了很多朋友，因为我无法原谅别人，而我自己也会犯下同样的错误。我一直在为此感到后悔。我希望自己当时能有先见之明，意识到：“哇，那真的太微不足道了。”那些问题，根本不算什么。但伤害已经造成了，是的，是由他们造成的，但也是由我造成的，因为我无法原谅。而且我觉得自己没法回头去说：“嘿，也许我错了”，因为我在自己的……
judgments. Now, I definitely have a much more, a broader forgiveness policy, which is sometimes less than healthy. I feel like sometimes I do let people get away with things, but I just like to see the good in people, and I think that's important. Most people aren't malicious. Most people are just careless, and a lot of their actions are forgivable if you remove your ego from it and see that, I don't know, I guess not everything is about you. Okay, number four, sometimes you are the asshole. recognize that you are the asshole. And you have to stop looking for reassurance and stop telling the story
判断上太固执己见了。现在，我绝对有了一个更宽容的宽容政策，有时候这甚至不太健康。我觉得有时候我确实对别人过于纵容了，但我就是喜欢看到人们善良的一面，我认为这很重要。大多数人并不是出于恶意。大多数人只是粗心大意，只要你把自我意识从中剥离出来，看到……我不知道，也许并非每件事都与你有关，那么他们的很多行为都是可以原谅的。好的，第四点，有时你就是个混蛋。承认你就是个混蛋。
30, 40, 50 different ways so that it makes you seem like you weren't the villain and that you were the good guy and spinning the situation so that you can feel in the clear. You weren't the good guy. You know you weren't the good guy. The next best thing you can do is to admit you screwed up and be better.
你必须停止寻求安慰，停止用30种、40种、50种不同的方式去讲述这个故事，好让自己看起来不是反派，而是好人，扭曲局面以便让自己觉得问心无愧。你当时并不是好人。你知道自己当时不是好人。你能做的下一件最好的事就是承认你搞砸了，然后变得更好。
I feel like there is so much ego protection going on in these situations where all we want to do is survive with our identity intact and we want to survive feeling like we are a good person. And the thing that good people do is that they admit when they were wrong. And they aren't just aware that other people make mistakes. They're aware that they make mistakes as well. And that's just a part of life. And holding it against yourself too tightly and too strongly actually means that you can never admit it. You can never admit that you have done something wrong because that in itself would injure your ego and injure your self-esteem so gravely that it's easier just to pretend and to convince yourself
我觉得在这些情况下有太多的自我保护机制，我们只想带着完整的自我认同活下去，我们希望觉得自己是个好人。而好人会做的事情，就是承认自己错了。他们不仅意识到别人会犯错，也意识到自己同样会犯错。而这只是生活的一部分。如果你对自己抓得太紧、责备得太严厉，实际上意味着你永远无法承认错误。你永远无法承认自己做错了事，因为那本身就会对你的自尊心造成如此严重的伤害，以至于伪装并说服自己……要容易得多。
that you're always in the right. And you're not. Sometimes you're in the wrong. And life gets a lot easier when you are able to admit that, especially in friendships, especially in relationships in general. Okay, I kind of like this trifecta thing. So speaking of relationships, let's do one more, like three for one deal. I have one specific relationship that there was one specific relationship in my 20s that informed so many of the lessons that I have on love. So I'm going to thank him and say sincerely, I hope you're doing well. But these tips all came from this and I think they're so valuable.
你总是对的。但你并不总是对的。有时候你就是错的。当你能够承认这一点时，生活就会变得轻松得多，尤其是在友谊中，尤其是在一般的关系中。好吧，我挺喜欢这种三合一的形式的。所以说到人际关系，我们再来一个像买三赠一一样的组合。我有一段特定的人际关系，在我20多岁的时候，正是这段关系让我对爱情有了许多领悟。所以我要感谢他，并真诚地说，希望你过得好。但这些建议都源于此，而且我认为它们非常有价值。
Don't get into a relationship right after a breakup. Just because you're thinking about someone doesn't mean they're the one. And allow yourself to get mad at the people who break your heart. and equally stand up for yourself when you're not being treated right. So I want to start with this first one. Don't get into a relationship straight after a breakup. I feel like a lot of you guys can relate. Everybody has to make this mistake at some point.
不要在刚分手后就立刻开始一段新的恋爱。仅仅因为你在想念某人并不意味着他就是真命天子。允许自己对伤透你心的人感到愤怒。同样，当受委屈时，也要勇敢为自己发声。所以我想从第一点开始。不要在分手后马上开始一段恋情。我觉得你们中的很多人都能感同身受。每个人在某个时候都必须犯这个错误。
I think it is in many ways a little bit of a ride of passage. But I did this and I remember being like, oh no, I'm totally healed. I'm totally fine. I'm totally ready for this. And that's just absolute nonsense. Like I had not processed a single thing and getting into a new relationship was just an excellent form of avoidance
我认为在许多方面这算是一种成人礼。但我当时就这么做了，我记得当时还想：“哦不，我完全治愈了。我完全没事了。我完全准备好了。”这纯粹是无稽之谈。我根本没有消化任何事情，开始一段新的恋爱只是一种极佳的逃避形式……
that looked like the opposite. Like it looked like moving on because it was the thing that was the most obvious form of moving on. But I was just finding myself in the same conditions and the same, yeah, the same conditions of feeling cared for, this guy I don't think he really cared for me, but feeling affection and thinking that that was like going to make my life better, the thing is is that you'll have all this unresolved stuff that is going to come out in that relationship
它看起来像是已经走了出来。它看起来像是在向前看，因为这是最显而易见的向前看的方式。但我发现自己依然处在相同的状态中，感受着同样的……是的，那种被照顾的感觉——虽然我觉得这个家伙并没有真正照顾我——但那种获得温情的感觉，让我觉得这会让我的生活变得更好。问题在于，你所有未解决的问题都会在那段关系中暴露无遗……
that is going to just mean that by the end of it, you're processing two heartbreaks on top of each other because you've never processed the one before. When this relationship inevitably ends, everything comes to the surface. Everything from both those situations becomes just like so apparent. and it's going to hurt. I say it's a lesson. Would I do it again? I would.
这意味着到最后，你其实是在叠加处理两段心碎，因为你从来没有真正处理过上一段。当这段关系不可避免地结束时，一切都会浮出水面。来自这两种情况的一切都会变得如此清晰，而且会非常痛苦。我说这是一个教训。如果再来一次，我还会这么做吗？我会的。
I do think that it was really valuable, and it was very valuable in getting me to where I am now. Both of those breakups are a big part of like the history of the psychology of your 20s. That second part of that trifecta, just because you're thinking about somebody doesn't mean they're the one. I feel like there were so many times where I would have a dream about somebody I used to be with or their name or the thought of them would pop into my head, and I would read so heavily into it that it would dictate my behavior.
我确实认为这段经历非常有价值，而且对于指引我走到今天这一步起到了非常重要的作用。这两次分手都是《The Psychology of Your 20s》历史的重要组成部分。那个三合一组合的第二部分，仅仅因为你在想念某人并不意味着他就是真命天子。我觉得有很多次，我会梦到以前交往过的人，或者他们的名字、对他们的思念会突然蹦进脑海，我会过度解读这些，并让它左右我的行为。
And understanding the psychology now that I didn't back then, I know that it's just my brain, and that was my brain, trying to figure out where to put those memories, and trying to figure out where to place that person. Back then, I thought every dream, every thought, every thing that reminded me of somebody was a sign that this was destiny and we were meant to be together,
结合我现在的心理学知识，而这是我以前所没有的，我知道那只是我的大脑，那只是我的大脑在试图弄清楚该把这些记忆放在哪里，并试图给这个人找个合适的位置。回到过去，我曾以为每一个梦、每一个想法、每一个让我想起某人的事物，都是命运的迹象，预示着我们天生就该在一起。
now I just realize it's just a coincidence. So if you're having those thoughts right now of like, oh my God, maybe they were the one, you think about a million different things every single day. This is just another one of those thoughts. It's your choice whether you read into it or whether you move past it. And my final point in this trifector of like semi-relationship advice. And to be honest, I don't know if it's good, but it's just the lessons I've learned. allow yourself to get mad after a breakup and allow yourself to really say what you need to say
现在我才意识到这只是一种巧合。所以如果你现在也有这种想法，觉得“哦天哪，也许他就是那个人”，你想想，你每天都会冒出成百上千种不同的想法。这只是其中又一个念头而已。你是选择过度解读它，还是选择释怀，全凭你自己的决定。而我在这份半恋爱建议的三合一总结中的最后一点，老实说，我不知道这算不算好建议，但这确实是我学到的教训：允许自己在分手后感到愤怒，并允许自己真正说出你需要说的话。
to stand up for yourself. I was having this conversation with my friend the other day who's recently ended a relationship or somebody has ended a relationship with her in a very unfair and cruel fashion. And she was like, do I say something? Do I reach out to him? And I said to her, and I'm being totally honest, if there is something that you wish you had said or still want to say, you should say it. And you should allow yourself to get angry because a lesson I've learned from having done that and not having done that in certain situations is that when there are things left unsaid, whether those are good or bad, you're always going to come back to it and linger on it.
坚持自我。前几天我和朋友聊天，她刚结束一段感情，或者说有人以一种非常不公平和残忍的方式结束了和她的感情。她当时问我：\"我要说点什么吗？我要联系他吗？\"我告诉她，而且我是完全出于真心：如果你有什么话当时没说出口，现在依然想说，那就说出来吧。你应该允许自己去生气，因为我从过去的经历中吸取到的教训是——无论在某些情况下做过还是没做过——当有些话没有说出口时，无论是好是坏，你总会忍不住回想起它，并对它念念不忘。
So if there is something like really heavy on your heart and somebody has really hurt you, they're allowed to feel that pain. you don't have to be the only one who carries what you've experienced. And if there is an opportunity for that kind of closure, I don't know if it's the healthiest thing in the world. I still think that you should take it because I think there is some healing and just saying your peace about how somebody has hurt you. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
所以，如果有什么事压在你心头让你感到非常沉重，而且有人真的伤害了你，你有权利去感受那种痛苦，你不必独自一人承受你所经历的一切。如果有这样一个能够了结的机会，虽然我不知道这算不算世界上最健康的做法，但我依然认为你应该抓住它，因为我觉得把对你造成伤害的人说清楚、表达出你的内心感受，本身就是一种治愈。百分之二。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《百分之二》。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardship. and you will come out on the other side
我将带你剖析我们这个奇怪的现代社会中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你抛弃主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经盲目相信种子油天生具有炎症性，但我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端迎来蜕变
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字的 2%。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时的情况，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊一聊快克，不过只是让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始发现这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把“艾滋病”这个话题摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会
get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在盲目追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯、
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines,
因为你觉得在人间走这一遭，做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？兄弟，因为这是两种不同的动机。完全正确。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地去做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
和我在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这就引发了一场长达数年的法律诉讼来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税钱被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的脑子当时都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trap》播客。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个高产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, I feel like we need a lighthearted one after that. I feel like that was very intense.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。好吧，我觉得在经历了刚才的事之后，我们需要一个轻松一点的话题。我觉得刚才那段太紧张了。
So number nine, practice some magic and don't neglect your spiritual practices. long-term listeners know that I had some really, let's say, intense experiences with the church in my teen years. I used to be very religious, used to be a big fan of Jesus. But after like some kind of poor encounters with some people, I kind of dropped away and lost belief. And that actually created a lot of emptiness. I think as humans, it's important we believe in something. and after 26 years, I feel like I now know that having spiritual practices and having a spiritual routine is just as important to me as having an exercise routine or having a budgeting routine
所以第九条，练习一些魔法，不要忽视你的精神修行。长期听众都知道，我在十几岁时有过一些非常、可以说是很激烈的教会经历。我过去非常虔诚，曾经是耶稣的超级粉丝。但在经历了一些与某些人的糟糕遭遇后，我逐渐疏远并失去了信仰。这其实造成了很大的空虚感。我认为作为人类，我们相信某些东西是很重要的。在经历了 26 年之后，我觉得我现在明白，拥有精神修行和精神例行公事对我来说，和拥有锻炼习惯、预算习惯
or a social life. Without it, I slip. I slip fast. So I really think that it's important that whether you are part of a religion or you're not, whether you're spiritual or not, you do have some kind of practices that unite you to something bigger. and unite you to others and allow you to see the thread that pulls of those experiences together. Some of the things that I do is I still sing worship songs sometimes. Like, I just, I like to sing. And honestly, worship music is amazing. Don't obviously believe everything that they're talking about.
或社交生活一样重要。没有它，我就会堕落。我会迅速堕落。所以我真的认为，无论你是否信仰某种宗教，无论你是否有灵性，拥有某种能将你与更伟大的事物联系在一起的修行是非常重要的。它能将你与他人联系起来，让你看到将这些经历串联在一起的线索。我做的一些事情包括：我有时仍然会唱赞美诗。就像，我只是喜欢唱歌。老实说，赞美音乐太棒了。当然，不要盲目相信他们所谈论的一切。
But it's amazing. And I think that having that, like, musical connections is important. I also like to practice picking one person who has annoyed me or frustrated me, like, once a week. and I like to think as many good things about that person as possible and wish everything good comes true for them and I like to imagine like a bubble coming out of me and surrounding them with positivity. I don't know, that's a really spiritual practice for me that keeps me grounded.
但它真的很棒。我觉得拥有这种音乐联系很重要。我还喜欢练习每周挑选一个曾惹恼我或让我沮丧的人，尽可能多地去想那个人的优点，并祝愿他一切都好，我喜欢想象一个泡泡从我体内涌出，用正能量包围着他们。我不知道，对我来说这是一种真正的精神修行，它能让我保持脚踏实地。
Something my church did as well that I still do, even though I don't believe in those, believe in it anymore, is when you get paid before you spend, you have to give back to others first. Or when you get served, you have to give the first piece of meat to somebody else first. I know like in the Mormon church, for example, they encourage people to give 10% of their earnings.
我的教会以前也做过一些事，我现在还在做，尽管我不再相信那些东西了。那就是：当你拿到薪水时，在消费之前，你必须先回馈他人。或者当你受到招待时，你必须先把第一块肉分给别人。我知道比如在摩门教里，他们鼓励人们捐出收入的 10%。
Some pagan traditions also have a similar thing of like serving others first or giving to others before you give to yourself. That's important for me, especially given the state of the world right now. And just having a good gratitude practice is so essential. Like hold tight to that stuff. That's a big lesson. You need it. You need spiritual practices to make you feel nourished. Similar to this, when you are feeling terrible about the world, be kind to small creatures. This is such an important lesson. Again, with the state of the world right now, it's very easy to feel very despondent, duh, it's very easy to feel terrible about the world. I like to imagine that humanity is this big experiment and there is this higher power who is judging our experiment on whether it was good or bad and whether humanity
一些异教传统也有类似的做法，比如把服务他人放在首位，或者在给予自己之前先给予他人。这对我来说很重要，尤其是考虑到目前世界局势。保持感恩的习惯是如此重要。紧紧抓住这些东西。这是一个深刻的教训。你需要它。你需要精神修行来让自己感到滋养。与此类似，当你对这个世界感到糟糕时，请对小生物好一点。这是一个非常重要的教训。同样，鉴于目前的全球局势，人们很容易感到沮丧，啊，很容易对世界感到糟糕。我喜欢把人类想象成这样一个宏大的实验，有一个更高力量的裁判在评判我们的实验是好是坏，以及人类
is succeeding or failing. And it's my job every single day to do something that proves the experiment is working and to do something that proves the hypothesis that humanity is good. And there is, it's going to sound a bit, a bit weird, but I imagine that there is this like tiny telescope or like microscope on me and they are watching me positively interact or watching people positively interact with each other and checking it down as evidence that people are good and taking care of small creatures honoring their lives appreciating them is a way that I do that like life is hard for little for little things life is hard for small creatures and sometimes knowing that like you know not just killing the answer that are in my house
是在成功还是在失败。而我每天的工作，就是做一些事情来证明这个实验正在发挥作用，并证明“人类是善良的”这一假设。而且——这听起来可能会有点奇怪——我想象自己身上有一个微型望远镜或显微镜，他们在观察我与他人积极互动，或者观察人们之间积极的互动，并把它记下来作为人们是善良的证据。照顾小生物、尊重它们的生命、欣赏它们，就是我践行这一点的方式。对于小东西来说，生活很艰难。对于小生物来说，生活很艰难。有时候，你知道的，不仅仅是不去杀死我屋子里的蚂蚁，
or not just killing the fly that's in my car or stopping for birds or saving a pigeon or something like that knowing that like I have kindness for them makes me feel like a higher power will have kindness for me and I don't know it just it makes me feel connected to what's around me that's an important lesson lesson number 11 if there is an opportunity to go to the beach you should always go the older you get, the more you realize the healing power of water and the healing power of nature. It's called the Lassar therapy. I'm a big proponent and I'm going to say nothing more about that lesson. I feel like that one's pretty obvious.
或者不杀死车里的苍蝇，或者为小鸟驻足，或者救一只鸽子诸如此类的事情，知道我对它们怀有善意，会让我觉得某种更高力量也会对我怀有善意。我不知道，这只是让我觉得与周围的事物产生了联系。这是一个重要的教训。第 11 条教训：如果有机会去海滩，你一定要去。人越老，就越能意识到水的治愈力量和大自然的治愈力量。这被称为拉萨疗法。我是它的坚定支持者，关于这个教训我不再多说了。我觉得这一条已经很明显了。
Lesson number 12, work hard at something even if it feels meaningless, whatever it is. Typically, I feel like we save all of our hard work for others. I honestly think we save all of our hard work for our boss, for our parents, for our co-workers, for people we want to impress. Save some of that hard work for you and use it for things that feel personally meaningful. There is so much good that comes from working hard, even if at the time it seems like there's no point or like nothing is going to come from it. Working hard on a novel, no one's going to read. Working hard on improving your running even though you never going to be a professional. Working hard on perfecting a recipe just for yourself or whatever it is,
第 12 条教训：努力做好某件事，即使它看起来毫无意义，无论是什么。通常情况下，我觉得我们把所有的努力都留给了别人。老实说，我认为我们把所有的努力都留给了老板、父母、同事、我们想要留下好印象的人。为你自己保留一些努力，把它用在对你个人有意义的事情上。努力工作会带来很多好处，即使在当时看来毫无意义，或者觉得不会有什么结果。努力写一本没有人会读的小说。努力提高跑步水平，尽管你永远不会成为专业运动员。努力完善一个只为自己享用的食谱，或者无论什么事，
so much personal reward for me has come from the joy I've just found from working hard for things that I care about and at the time, which is fun, but you never know where it's going to take you. This podcast is a great example. Like, I didn't know this is going to happen. I just liked working hard at it. And I just have a deep belief that the universe or the forces that be reward hard work and like to see passion. And so when it sees somebody working hard, proving that they will work hard in the future for no reward, just for joy and personal pursuit and personal passion, good things come to those people because of those practices. It is a reward in itself to care. But I also feel like when you put yourself in the place where you do care, people like to see other people who care.
我从为自己关心的事物努力工作所获得的快乐中，收获了巨大的个人回报。当时这很有趣，但你永远不知道它会把你带向何方。这个播客就是一个很好的例子。比如，我以前不知道会发生这一切。我只是喜欢努力做好它。我深信，宇宙或冥冥之中的力量会奖励努力工作，并且喜欢看到热情。因此，当它看到有人在努力工作，证明他们未来会为了毫无回报、仅仅为了快乐、个人追求和个人热情而努力工作时，美好事情就会降临到这些人身上，正是因为这些修行。关怀本身就是一种回报。但我也觉得，当你把自己放在一个你确实在乎的位置时，人们喜欢看到其他在乎的人。
And they like to see people who are passionate about something and you'll find that opportunities come so much more naturally to you. People rally around you when, yeah, when there's something bigger than you that you're invested in and that you're willing to work hard for. So if there's not something in your life right now that you are working hard for, even if it's only working hard for 20 minutes a week, I really think your life would benefit from finding something that you want to give that time to. Okay, number 13, lesson 13, this is a lesson that I didn't want to look. I was hesitant to learn, but it was too obvious to ignore. You are always going to feel better if you don't go on your phone first thing in the morning. Why did this take me so long to learn?
他们喜欢看到对某事充满热情的人，你会发现机会会更自然地降临到你身上。当有比你更伟大的事情让你投入其中，并且你愿意为之付出努力时，人们就会团结在你周围。所以，如果你的生活中现在还没有什么事情是你正在努力去做的，哪怕每周只花 20 分钟去努力，我真的认为你的生活会因为找到一件你愿意投入时间的事情而受益。好的，第 13 条，第 13 个教训，这是一个我本不想面对的教训。我一开始很犹豫要不要学，但它实在太明显，无法忽视。如果你一大早不看手机，你的感觉总是会好一些。为什么我花了这么久才明白这个道理？
I don't know. Obviously our phones are addictive. That feels like a cop out. that feels like an excuse. There's all this buzz around like going analog and the digital detox and being social media free and offline activities. And having like really tried to be in that space, it is really incredible. But if that feels too big, I feel like this is the simplest thing.
我不知道。显然我们的手机会让人上瘾。这听起来像是个借口，听起来像是个推脱。现在到处都是关于回归模拟、数字排毒、摆脱社交媒体和线下活动的风潮。我真的很努力地去尝试那种状态，感觉确实非常不可思议。但如果这让人觉得步子迈得太大，我觉得这是一个最简单的办法。
You know, I tried to do the flip phone on weekends. I tried to give myself social media boundaries. It worked for a while. I think I went too big with it. This is a great starting point. Just not going on your phone first thing in the morning will change the course of your entire day. Because the moment you put that phone in front of your face, it's like you're immediately like sucked into someone else's world. You're immediately, I guess a little bit brain dead, to be honest.
你知道，我试过在周末用翻盖手机。我试着给自己的社交媒体设定界限。它管用了一段时间。我想我当时把目标定得太大了。这是一个很好的起点。只要一大早不看手机，就会改变你整整一天的人生轨迹。因为当你把手机举到脸前的那一说，你就像是被瞬间吸进了别人的世界。老实说，你立刻就会变得有点脑死亡。
And I'm saying this is somebody who still does it occasionally. It's like if that's the first thing you look at, how. you were expected to then go forward with the rest of your day being curious or being entertained by the smaller things or noticing things when it's like it's like you're hooked up to this like ivy drip of entertainment so give yourself at least 20 30 minutes to just experience being alive without a phone and without this thing that contains the entire world inside of it um yeah at least first thing in the morning I think you will notice a difference. I definitely did.
我是以一个偶尔还会这么做的人的身份说这话的。这就好比如果那是你睁眼看的第一样东西，你怎么能指望接下来的一整天还能保持好奇心，或者被微小的事物逗乐，或者注意到周围的细节呢？这就好像你被连上了娱乐的静脉注射滴管一样。所以，给自己至少 20 到 30 分钟的时间，去体验没有手机、没有这个包罗万象的物件的纯粹活着的感觉。嗯，是的，至少在刚醒来的那一会儿，我想你会注意到不一样的变化。我确实感觉到了。
Okay, so lesson number 14, another really important one, but a little bit more serious. Stop trying to be them. Whoever them is to you, it doesn't matter. Whether it's a celebrity, a friend, a nemesis, a parent, like, you will never be successful when the goal is imitation. and you will drive yourself mad, trying to correct and police and mould yourself into an identity that doesn't come naturally because it's not yours. I did this for ages. I was so easily influenced because I guess there's just something really alluring about people who seem to know themselves and who have an identity or who have a brand, who have a distinct thing to them that's attractive when I didn't have that. guess what? By trying to imitate them, by trying to be them, I actually knew myself less
好吧，第14课，同样非常重要，但稍微严肃一点。停止试图成为他们。无论“他们”对你来说是谁，这都不重要。不管是名人、朋友、死敌、还是父母，当你的目标是模仿时，你永远不会成功，而且你会把自己逼疯，试图纠正、管束和塑造自己，变成一个不自然的身份，因为它根本不属于你。我这样做了很久。我太容易受到影响了，因为我猜，那些似乎很了解自己、有自己的身份、有自己的品牌、有自己独特的吸引力的人，对我来说有一种真正的诱惑力，而我当时却没有这些。你猜怎么着？通过试图模仿他们，通过试图成为他们，我实际上对自己了解得更少了。
because I would constantly compare the beginning of my own new self and my own identity to their complete one. Guys, it's so cliche, I know, but I fully believe, I fully believe there is a unique version of us. We are all here to be a unique avatar and we are all meant to be individual and we're meant to grow in a specific way and we are meant to exist in a specific form and live a specific life and imitation is one of the main things that's going to block us and that's going to stop us from living out our mission and living out our identity and living out our role in the world and I know this episode is getting so woo-woo but just notice it in yourself there is there isn't an identity there is
因为我会不断地把我刚刚开始的新自我和我的个人身份与他们完整的身份进行比较。大家，我知道这听起来太老套了，但我完全相信，我完全相信我们都有一个独一无二的版本。我们来到这里都是为了成为一个独特的化身，我们都注定要成为独立的个体，我们注定要以特定方式成长，注定要以特定形式存在并过上特定的生活，而模仿是阻碍我们的主要因素之一，它会阻止我们实现我们的使命、活出我们的身份并在世界上发挥我们的作用。我知道这集内容听起来太玄乎了，但只要注意你内心的感受，就会发现有一个身份，有一个
a version of you that you're, you just feel constantly drawn to and drawn back to and drawn into and it's like such a powerful force. Stop trying to suppress that. Stop putting imitation in between you and that version of you. That new version of you. Okay, lesson number 15. Sometimes you are the bad day and you need to call yourself on it. This is probably the most recent lesson on the list. probably a lesson I only learned a couple of weeks ago if I'm being completely honest um
你一直在不断被吸引、被拉回、被吸引进去的那个版本的你，那真是一股强大的力量。停止试图压抑这种感觉。不要再把模仿横亘在你和那个版本的你之间。那个全新的你。好的，第15课。有时你就是糟糕的一天本身，你需要直面并承认这一点。这可能是清单上最近的一课。如果说实话的话，这可能是我几周前才学会的一课，嗯，
hill the day I just had I said this terrible day the other day and my boyfriend was snoring I love him but I don't know what he like turned 27 and suddenly like nasal congestion is his middle name
天哪，我刚刚经历的一天。前几天我度过了糟糕的一天，我男朋友在打呼噜，我爱他，但我不知道他怎么回事，就像是刚满27岁，突然之间，鼻塞就成了他的代名词。
I love you Tom but hopefully he doesn't hear that but he was snoring and so I had a really bad night's sleep and then I went to like transfer money onto my UK card and it wasn't working. And then I went and got a bagel at the, like, the corner store and my bagel, like, fell apart on the street. And this, like, little dog came up and, like, ate tuna from my tuna bagel, like, from where it was
我爱你，汤姆，希望他听不到这话。但他当时在打呼噜，所以我昨晚没睡好。然后我去把钱转到我的英国银行卡上，结果转账失败了。接着我去街角便利店买了一个贝果，我的贝果在街上散架了。然后一只小狗跑过来，吃掉了我金枪鱼贝果里的金枪鱼，就从它掉在地上的
on the floor. And then I went to meet my friend, and I was running late, and I couldn't get a line bike. And then when I got a line bike, it was broken. And I was like, this day just sucks. And I was in such a terrible mood. And I was so angry. I was like, what did I do to deserve this? Like, this is just such a terrible day. And then I was like, yeah, but I'm being the bad day. Like, all those things are annoying. But what's really the problem here?
地方。然后我去见朋友，结果我迟到了，还借不到一辆共享单车。好不容易借到了一辆，结果还是坏的。当时我就想，这一天简直糟透了。我的心情变得极其糟糕，也非常生气。我想，我到底做了什么才落得这般田地？这简直太倒霉了。然后我转念一想，不对，其实是我自己把这一天过糟糕了。所有这些事情确实很烦人，但这里真正的问题到底是什么？
Oh, like, how terrible. The man that I love, who loves me, who is like the most glorious, beautiful person I've ever met, like, he snores, and that disturbs my sleep. And, like, oh, I have enough money in my bank account to transfer it onto my British card because I had enough privilege to move overseas. And, oh, the bagel that I could. afford getting it takeaway rather than having to make it at home fell on the street and this I got to meet a dog who was eating my bagel and like oh my friends I've my friend who has made plans with me I'm late to and like where was me and I was just like I'm the bad day right now like I'm reading way too much into this and I am investing too much in my identity here as a victim when actually like
哦，真是太糟糕了。我深爱的那个男人，他也爱我，他是那种我见过最辉煌、最美丽的人，他竟然会打呼噜，这打扰了我的睡眠。而且，我的银行账户里有足够的钱可以转到我的英国卡上，因为我有足够的特权去海外生活。还有，我明明买得起外卖贝果，不用自己在家做，结果它掉在街上，我还能遇到一只吃我贝果的小狗。还有，我约了朋友但我迟到了，我还在这自怨自艾。当时我就觉得自己简直就像个灾难本身——我把事情看得太严重了，而且我在这里过度投入了自己作为受害者的身份，而实际上——
all of those things that I've experienced that I thought were like the worst things that it were going to happen to me that day are just like privileges and just wonderful things that I don't know people would kill to have those inconveniences so just recognize when you're ruining your own day and just try and pull yourself out of it number 16 another quick one take your medications regularly and are scheduled and that goes for antibiotics antidepressants panadol pain relief anything prescribed to you by a doctor doctor, listen to them. And bonus, 16.2, just go to the dentist. Go to the dentist. You know you need to. I put up going to the dentist for six years, and I'm ashamed to admit that. But it's because
我经历的所有那些我以为是那天能发生的最糟糕的事情，其实都只是特权，都只是些美妙的事情，我不知道有多少人愿意付出一切来换取这些不便。所以，认清什么时候是你自己在毁掉自己的一天，然后试着把自己从这种状态中拉出来。第16课，另一个简短的建议：按时按计划服用药物。这适用于抗生素、抗抑郁药、扑热息痛、止痛药以及医生开具的任何药物，听医生的。还有一个附加项，16.2，去看牙医。去看牙医吧。你知道你需要去的。我拖了六年没去看牙医，我很不好意思承认这一点。但这是因为
the last time I went, it really hurt. And I was really scared. And guess what? Guess what that got me? When I went last year, seven fillings, $3,000 worth of dental work that could have been avoided. If I just went more regularly, the older you get, the more you get, the more you. you stop taking your health for granted and the more you realize that there are people who train for many, many years to be experts in this and to know what they're doing, um, listen to them and take care of yourself. Take your meds are scheduled, go to the dentist. 17. When somebody is mean to you or short with you, the best defense and the only defense that will work in your favor is to be disgustingly kind back. And I learned this.
上次我去的时候真的很痛。我当时真的很害怕。你猜怎么着？你猜那给我带来了什么？我去年去的时候，补了七颗牙，花了3000美元的牙科费用，而这些本来是可以避免的。如果我能更经常去的话。你年纪越大，就会越发不再把健康视为理所当然，也会越发意识到有些人经过了多年专业训练，成为了这方面的专家并且知道自己在做什么。嗯，听他们的，照顾好自己。按时吃药，去看牙医。第17课。当有人对你刻薄或态度生硬时，最有效的防守、也是唯一能对你有利的防守，就是以极其恶心人的善良回击。我通过
through trial and error. But when people were like used to be mean to me or you know when people make those slight jabs like they're trying to get under your skin and they think you don't notice and they're trying to like bring you down a peg, I used to get quite, I wouldn't say mad, but I would just, I would have a certain reaction. Like I would either avoid them or like I would try and be smart back or I would like try and make other people realize what kind of person they were. And then I just realize the best thing that you can do. And I talked about this in our episode on how to not take things personally. It's just to be so nice and so kind and so generous and so forgiving with them that they have like no choice but just to have this mirror placed in front of them that makes them
不断的试错才学到了这一点。以前当别人对我刻薄，或者你知道当人们说那些暗讽的话，试图触及你的底线，而他们以为你没注意到，还想把你踩下去的时候，我过去常常会变得——倒也不是生气，但我会有某种反应。比如我要么避开他们，要么试图在言语上回击，或者我会试图让其他人看清他们到底是什么样的人。后来我才意识到你能做的最好的事情。我在关于“如何不把事情放心上”的那期节目里聊过这个。那就是对他们好到极点、善良到极点、慷慨到极点、包容到极点，以至于他们别无选择，只能面对一面镜子，让他们
directly see how weird and gross and terrible their behavior is. This doesn't mean permissive. I don't mean you have to continue to let them in your life. and continue to let them walk all over you and continue to give in to them. Be kind, be nice, still set boundaries, but it is genuinely like one of the most powerful things that we can do psychologically to just cut someone's cruelty off and to just essentially stop them from, yeah, thinking that they can treat you that way and thinking that their behavior isn't a problem. number 18
直接看到自己诡异、恶心和糟糕的行为是多么的不堪。这并不意味着纵容。我不是说你必须继续让他们进入你的生活，继续让他们践踏你，继续向他们妥协。保持善良，保持友好，但依然要设定界限。然而从心理学角度来看，这确实是最强大的手段之一，能够直接切断某人的残酷，从根本上阻止他们——是的——认为自己可以那样对你，并且认为他们的行为没有问题。第18课
you don't need to help everybody I know that like a lot of these tips have been like be kind be generous be nice forgive be good friend somebody some people just don't deserve that some people just don't deserve your help and part of being a good friend
你不需要帮助所有人。我知道，上面很多建议都在强调：要善良、要慷慨、要友好、要宽容、要做一个好朋友，但有些人根本不配得到这些。有些人就是不配得到你的帮助。而作为好朋友的一部分，
part of being a good member of the village member of the tribe the community that you're in is knowing that you can't give everybody everything that you have have. And that one of the most generous things that you can do is to take care of yourself first so that you can show up for the people who really deserve you, rather than doing favors for everybody, you know, putting yourself out there for everybody, saying yes to everybody,
作为村庄里的一员、部落里的一员、你所在的社区里的一员的一部分，就是明白你不可能把拥有的所有东西都分给所有人。最慷慨的事情之一，就是先照顾好你自己，这样你才能出现在真正值得你付出的人身边，而不是对所有人都百依百顺，你知道的，为了所有人把自己搭进去，对所有人都说“好”，
to the point of exhaustion. And when the time really comes to be there for those who would do the same things back for you, being so burnt out that you're not able to do that. And I feel like this is a very specific lesson that you learn in specific circumstances, especially if you are very hyper-independent, especially if you are an eldest daughter or an eldest daughter, high achiever type. Eventually you learn that there are some people who just don't need your help, not because they don't deserve help from anybody, but because you and your energy and your time is a precious resource. Similar to this is lesson number 19. Trust your gut when to say no, when to not go to the party. when to not help your friend with some crazy idea they have.
直到精疲力竭。而当真正需要你支持那些同样会为你付出的人时，你却已经精疲力竭，无能为力了。我觉得这是一门非常具体的课，你会在特定的情况下学到它，特别是当你极度独立的时候，特别是如果你是长女，或者是那种追求卓越的长女类型。最终你会明白，有些人就是不需要你的帮助，不是因为他们不配得到任何人的帮助，而是因为你、你的精力和你的时间是宝贵的资源。与此类似的是第19课。当该说不的时候，相信你的直觉；当不想去派对的时候，就不要去；当不想帮朋友处理他们那些疯狂的想法时，就拒绝。
Obviously, like, you want to be a good friend and you want to give back, but there are just some things where you're allowed to just be like, I don't have time for that. And especially when it's for people who would never do the same thing for you in return and who you resent constantly for not returning the favour, that is a sign that, like, they're taking advantage. And it's okay to just, it's okay to just take a step back. and to not give them everything you've got and to say no.
显然，你想成为一个好朋友，你想给予回报，但有些事情你完全可以直说：“我没有时间。”尤其是当面对那些从来不会为你做同样的事情，并且会让你因为他们不感恩而不断心生怨恨的人时，这就是一个他们在占便宜的信号。退一步海阔天空，不必把所有东西都给他们，学会说“不”，这是完全可以的。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too. complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇妙的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。就在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对谈，畅聊80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，只是让大家知道而已。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始发现这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆到了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为还有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you Get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn The Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是——特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough, Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是说你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
加入我的新播客《Learn The Hard Way》，由我卡尔·盖恩斯带你深入探讨疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力与人生目标等真实话题。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn The Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你在这份特定的测试中作假了两次，对吗？我作假测试了一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天呐，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》这个新季中，“哦，天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的世纪骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说：“哦，见鬼，不。”我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Lesson number 20, you do actually feel better when you exercise more and drink less, which sucks. See, I like alcohol. I like, I like alcohol. I do. I like alcohol. I also, I like exercising. But I wish I didn't have to do them as much as I do. Or I wish, I wish that, like, I could go to the gym like once a week and drink every night and feel amazing. And it's just not how your body is, right? When I was definitely, when I was younger, when I was like 17, 18, 19, and I was at university, I would, like, we would, like, binge drinking. We were, like, drinking every single night.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。第20课，多运动少喝酒，你确实会感觉更好，这真让人不爽。你看，我喜欢酒精。我喜欢，我喜欢酒精。我是真的喜欢。我也喜欢运动。但我希望我不必像现在这样频繁地去做。或者我希望，我希望，比如说，我可以每周去一次健身房，每天晚上都喝酒，然后感觉好极了。但你的身体根本不是这样的，对吧？当我确确实实，当我年轻的时候，当我大概17、18、19岁在读大学的时候，我就会，就像，我们就会，疯狂酗酒。我们就是，每天晚上都在喝酒。
And nobody was blinking an eye. And we would, like, go on, like, one 5K run or, like, play some, like, frisbee once a week. And I remember being like, oh, why do I feel so tired? And, like, why am I exhausted all the time? And why do I feel disgusting? and then slowly, like, as those habits became more and more difficult to maintain and more repulsive, and you start adding some exercise back in and you start realizing that drinking every, drinking on a Monday with your powers is probably not healthy.
而且没有人会眨一下眼睛。我们还会，比如，去进行一次5公里跑步，或者每周玩一次飞盘。我记得当时我就在想，天哪，为什么我这么累？而且，为什么我一直筋疲力尽？为什么我觉得自己糟透了？然后慢慢地，随着这些习惯变得越来越难以维持、越来越让人反感，你开始重新增加一些运动，你开始意识到，每天喝酒，在周一和朋友们一起喝酒可能并不健康。
I was like, wow, I actually feel better. And my habits are a reflection of like the quality of life that I want and how I want to live my life. So that's definitely been an important lesson, one that I wish wasn't true. But unfortunately is you do feel a lot better to go on a completely different direction here, lesson 21, wait 24 hours before making an impulse purchase. I feel like these are all tips of just like learning impulse control and learning what it means to be healthy, financially, emotionally, physically. I had a real impulse shopping problem when I was probably like 22, 23 in my early 20s when I first got like a proper job. And I would just buy the most ridiculous stuff because I would
我当时就想，哇，我真的感觉好多了。我的习惯反映了我想要的生活品质以及我希望如何度过我的人生。所以这绝对是一个重要的教训，一个我希望它不是真的教训。但不幸的是，事实就是当你换一个完全不同的方向时，你确实会感觉好很多，第21课，在进行冲动消费前等待24小时。我觉得这些都只是一些关于学会冲动控制以及理解在财务、情感和身体上保持健康意味着什么的小贴士。在我大概22、23岁刚找到第一份正式工作的二十出头时，我确实有很严重的冲动购物问题。我总是会买一些最荒谬的东西，因为我会
see it, think I needed it. And because I now had access to adult money, I could just buy it. And genuinely, like, I think about how much money I wasted on multiple pairs of black jeans or just like, silly things that nobody needs. Now, this was the best thing I did for all the impulse shopping tips that you may get for all the budgeting tips. If there is something I want and I feel like I immediately need it, 24 hours, 24 hours before I can make the decision. And I think I've spoken about this before.
看到它，觉得我需要它。而且因为我现在有了花成年人钱的底气，我就可以直接买下来。说实话，我就在想，我在多条黑色牛仔裤或者根本没人需要的傻里傻气的东西上浪费了多少钱。现在，这是我为所有你可能听到的冲动购物建议、所有预算建议所做过的最好的事情。如果有什么东西是我想要的，而且我觉得我立刻就需要它，那就等24小时，在我做出决定前等24小时。我想我以前也谈过这个。
I have a list of my phone. Often by the time I get to that 24-hour mark, I've forgotten about it. and like the haze of like the emotional pull of dopamine of buying something and getting it delivered and like that kind of fades a little bit and I can kind of self-regulate. I also feel like impulse dropping, drinking, saying yes to everybody, those last three tips, often those are forms of avoidance. I've definitely found that. And so learning how to regulate your emotions without those things, the older you get,
我在手机里有一个清单。通常等我撑过这24小时的时候，我已经把它忘得精光了。而且就像那种由买东西并将其送货上门所带来的多巴胺情感吸引力的迷雾逐渐消散了一点，我就可以进行自我调节了。我也觉得冲动购物、喝酒、对所有人都说好，这最后三个小贴士，通常都是逃避的形式。我确实深有同感。所以学会如何在没有这些东西的情况下调节自己的情绪，随着年龄的增长，
the more important that becomes. Lesson 22, talk to your siblings more. Honestly, I found that because me and my sisters had such an age difference and because I moved out when they were so young, like, I think they were like 12 and 10, like they were still children. I don't even have like memories from when I was 10. I just didn't form the relationship with them that they form with each other. And I was very, very jealous of that for a long time. And it definitely was reflected in like my relationship with them where I would, I just felt very left out.
这一点变得越来越重要。第22课，多和你的兄弟姐妹聊天。老实说，我发现由于我和妹妹们的年龄差距很大，而且我在她们很小的时候就搬出去了，我觉得当时她们大概才12岁和10岁，她们还是小孩子。我甚至连自己10岁时的记忆都没有。我就是没能和她们建立起她们彼此之间那种关系。很长一段时间里，我对此感到非常非常嫉妒。这绝对反映在我与她们的关系上，我会，我只是觉得自己被冷落了。
And that felt weak because I was the older, I was the older sibling. Like, I meant to be the cool one and I would go back and they wouldn't really want anything to do with me. And for a couple of years, I was like, well, fine. I'm just going to hang out with my friends. And I didn't really have a relationship with my sisters. And then I think last year, I really started seeing them more. started realizing what an important relationship the sibling relationship is and how they are just like an inbuilt, amazing, cool best friend. And just the, you just relate to them on such a beautiful,
而这让我觉得很软弱，因为我是年长的，我是年长的那个。就像，我本该是那个酷的人，但我回去时她们其实并不怎么想理我。有那么好几年，我就想，好吧，那就算了。我要去和我的朋友们玩了。我跟我的妹妹们其实并没有什么真正的关系。然后我想去年，我真的开始更多地见到她们。开始意识到兄弟姐妹的关系是多么重要的一种关系，以及她们就像是一个自带的、超棒的、很酷的死党。那种感觉就是，你与她们产生共鸣的方式是如此美好、
simplistic, carefree level. And I think I started to really appreciate like my sister's personalities. And all the things about them that are so cool and that I love. And now I talk to them all the time. and that has been a huge, huge blessing for me and like just a huge, a huge gain in the past year. So if I was to go back three years, I'd be like, freaking call them, call them on the weekends, like text them, have a relationship. I regret not investing in that sooner and I feel like I missed a lot of their teen years trying to figure out my late teen years and my early 20s and being really sad. selfish with it. And now I feel like I've orbited back around right as they are orbiting out. And I
简单、无忧无虑。我想我开始真正欣赏我妹妹们的个性。以及她们身上所有那些那么酷、让我喜爱的地方。现在我经常和她们聊天。这对我来说一直是一个巨大无比的祝福，就像在过去的一年里获得了一笔巨大的财富。所以如果让我回到三年前，我会对自己说：快去打电话，周末给她们打电话，发信息，维系好关系。我很后悔没有早点在这上面投入精力，我觉得我为了弄清楚自己十几岁时的末期和二十岁出头并感到无比自私，错过了她们许多青春期。现在我觉得我又绕回了她们的轨道，正好赶上她们渐渐步入成年的边缘，而我
just hope that our relationship stays strong within that because it is just such a beautiful, one-of-a-kind, special relationship. Lesson 23. Celebrate yourself. Don't be afraid to make a big deal out of the things that you're proud of, even if nobody else is going to do it for you. Throw the birthday party for yourself. Organize the dinner with your friends for your job promotion. Make a big deal out of what feels like a big deal for you. Think of my children we're so used to our parents being so in our business or like our school or whatever it is like a mentor, aunts, grandparents, celebrating us. And then you get older and you realize like sometimes you've got to do that for yourself. And people want an excuse to party. People want an excuse to be excited
只希望我们的关系能在其中保持坚固，因为这真的是一段非常美好、独一无二、特别的关系。第23课。庆祝你自己。不要害怕大肆庆祝那些让你感到骄傲的事情，即使没有人会为你这么做。给自己办一场生日派对。为你的职位晋升组织一场与朋友们的晚宴。把你觉得是大事的事情当成真正的大事来大肆庆祝。想想我们的孩子们，我们太习惯于父母对我们的事情极其关注，或者我们的学校、不管是哪种导师、阿姨、祖父母为我们庆祝了。然后当你长大了，你就会意识到有时候你必须为自己做这件事。人们想要一个派对的借口。人们想要一个为你
for you. I would always feel a little bit cringe being like, oh, I'm going to plan like a birthday party or like I'm going to play like I want to celebrate this and I and now I don't feel any shame about it and having that space to invite people into my memories and knowing that I'm going to look back at those really cool things and they're going to be in those memories with me that is so important and that is so valuable and I just feel like celebrating yourself we don't do it enough and we don't make a big deal out of what a pleasure and a surprise and a beautiful thing it is to be alive and the fact that We work really hard and we do really cool things, things that younger you could not have imagined you doing.
感到兴奋的借口。我以前总是会觉得有点不好意思，想着：哦，我要计划一个生日派对，或者我要大肆宣扬我想庆祝这件事。而现在我对此毫无羞耻感，拥有这样一个空间去邀请人们进入我的回忆，并知道我回首那些非常酷的事情时，他们会和我的回忆融为一体，这太重要了，也太有价值了。我只是觉得庆祝自己这件事，我们做得还不够，我们也没有把活着是一件多么令人愉快、惊喜和美好的事情当成一件大事，我们工作真的很努力，我们做了很多很酷的事情，那些年轻时的你无法想象自己能做到的事情。
You are allowed to just be your biggest fan and your biggest cheerleader and make the space for other people to enter into that with you if they want to. And if they don't, that's okay. You get more cake. You get more champagne. You get more flowers. Make sure you make your big moments big for yourself. Lesson 24.
你完全可以成为自己最大的粉丝和最大的啦啦队队长，并腾出空间让其他人如果你愿意的话也参与进来。如果他们不想，也没关系。你可以吃更多蛋糕。你可以喝更多香槟。你可以收到更多鲜花。一定要把你的重要时刻对你自己而言变成真正的大事。第24课。
You can truly DIY your dream life. If you just commit to learning how to do things for yourself and learning how to do them badly, then a bit better than good, then amazingly. This is like the hack. This is the life hack that everybody needs to know. If you want to do something, oh my God, this sounds stupid now that I'm saying it, but if you want to do something, you should just do it. And you should just do it as simply and easily as you can possibly do at that point and then get better.
你完全可以亲手打造你的梦想生活。如果你只是承诺学会为自己做事，并学会一开始做得不好，然后做得比好一点点，再到做得惊艳。这就是秘诀。这是每个人都需要知道的生活秘诀。如果你想做一件事，天哪，我现在说这话听起来可能很蠢，但如果你想做一件事，你就应该直接去做。而且你应该以你当时能想到的最简单、最轻松的方式去做，然后再慢慢变好。
everybody I know who is really successful and who I really admire and who I now get to call my friends just went into it with this like do it myself attitude of being like nobody's going to hand this to me nobody's going to give me the keys to the life I want nobody's going to build the home I want for myself or the career I want for myself I have to do it myself and I have to like be in those meetings and I have to be in those emails called emailing somebody to see if they have an opportunity for me and I need to be creating my own product, creating my own business, creating my own podcast, and the universe will reward that. And I think it's similar to that previous tip of like do things just for the sake of it, experience hard effort just because hard effort is enjoyable for you
我认识的每一个真正成功、我真心仰慕、现在能称之为朋友的人，都是抱着这种“自己动手”的态度投入进去的，他们觉得：没有人会把这送到我手上，没有人会给我开启想要生活的钥匙，没有人会为我自己建造我想要的家或我想要的事业，我必须自己去完成。我必须参加那些会议，我必须发那些电子邮件去冷邮件联系别人，看看他们是否能为我提供机会。我需要创造我自己的产品，创造我自己的业务，创造我自己的播客，而宇宙会回报这一点的。我认为这类似于前面那个小贴士，就是为了做而做，去体验艰辛的努力，仅仅因为艰辛的努力能让你在做自己关心的事时感到快乐
when you're doing something you care about. This is very similar to this. When you truly realize that you can DIY, do it yourself, make it from scratch your dream life in the most rudimentary way possible in whatever, using whatever tools you have possible, your life seriously changes. And I, I don't like bragging, but I do feel like there's points in my, like my life is kind of evidence of that where, I don't know, I just didn't see a job for me. I didn't see a system that I enjoyed. And I was like, okay, well, I'll just make it myself. And if it works out, great, amazing. Obviously, that's what I want. And if it doesn't, at least I can say that I did it. At least I know that the opportunity wasn't out there waiting for me to arrive, waiting. Waiting.
这和那个非常相似。当你真正意识到你可以自己动手、从零开始以最简陋的方式、利用你身边可能拥有的任何工具去打造你的梦想生活时，你的生活真的会发生改变。我，我虽然不喜欢吹牛，但我确实觉得我生活中的某些时刻就是这种证明。我不知道，我只是没有看到一份适合我的工作。我没有看到一个我喜欢的系统。于是我想，好吧，那我就自己创造一个。如果成功了，太棒了，简直绝妙。显然，这就是我想要的。如果没有成功，至少我可以对自己说我做过。至少我知道机会并不是一直在那里等着我的到来，一直在等。
for me to get to the point where I was ready. Lesson 25, I actually think this one should have been before, but I'm sneaking it in at the end. 25, not every person you date is your soulmate. And it doesn't mean the relationship wasn't worthwhile. Additionally, when you are in your 20s, date as much as possible. I feel like I've learned this both through myself and through other people I've seen who have dated one person and been like, okay, cool, that seems like good enough. And then seven, eight years later, I've been like, oh, my God, I actually never got to experience what else was out there.
着我达到准备就绪的时刻。第25课，其实我觉得这一条应该放在前面，但我把它塞在了最后。25，你约会的每一个人都不是你的灵魂伴侣。这并不意味着这段关系不值得。此外，当你二十多岁时，尽可能多地去约会。我觉得我通过自己以及通过我看到的其他人意识到了这一点，他们只和一个人约会过，然后觉得：行，酷，这好像已经足够好了。然后七、八年后，我一直在想：哦，天哪，我其实从来没有体验过外面还有什么。
And I know not everybody agrees with this and people have different, you know, perspectives on it. But as much as my heart was broken many times, and I was literally reflecting on this the other day, like, all these guys I completely forgot about it. And as much as like it really hurt to be hurt by them and to be rejected by them, I'm so glad I did it.
我知道并非所有人都同意这一点，人们有不同的看法。但尽管我的心碎过很多次，我前几天还在反思这件事，那些我完全忘得精光的家伙们。尽管被他们伤害和拒绝真的很痛，但我非常庆幸我经历过。
and they all taught me important lessons. And every single relationship that I've had, even the ones that were a disaster, have been worthwhile because they brought me experiences that I otherwise would have had a lot of what-ifs swirling around. I know, again, I feel weird saying this because I know people might take it the wrong way of like just date for the sake of dating
他们都教给了我重要的课程。我经历过的每一段关系，甚至是那些一团糟的关系，都是值得的，因为它们带给我一些体验，否则我心里就会充满各种“如果当初”的假设。我知道，再次说明，我觉得说这话感觉怪怪的，因为我知道人们可能会曲解我的意思，以为我只是为了约会而约会
and like use other people for experience. No, I'm just saying put yourself out there and even if you're not entirely sure if this person is or isn't the one, give them a chance, have fun, experience each other, experience life together, even if that's for two weeks, two years, 20 years, and take the experiences you can get from really caring about somebody else, really having important memories with them, even if you know it's not going to be forever. I have two final lessons, a silly one and a serious one. let's start with this only one
或者把别人当作积累经验的工具。不，我只是说去勇敢尝试，即使你并不完全确定这个人是不是你的真命天子或真命天女，也要给彼此一个机会，去享受乐趣，去体验彼此，一起体验生活，哪怕这段经历只有两周、两年、二十年，并从真正关心另一个人、与他们拥有重要回忆中汲取你能获得的体验，哪怕你知道这段关系不会永远持续。我有最后两个教训，一个轻松的和一个严肃的，让我们从这个轻松的开始
dye your hair at least once in your life try a weird hairstyle even if you think slash no that it's going to be ugly I cannot recommend this enough I have dyed my hair black that was a terrible decision I have dyed my I've bleached my hair more times than I can think of
一生中至少染一次头发，尝试一个奇怪的发型，即使你认为或者明知道它会很难看。我极力推荐这个。我曾经把头发染成黑色，那真是一个糟糕的决定。我把头发漂过的次数多得我都数不清了
and it was often related to how I was emotionally doing at that point But like I have just done the craziest stupidest things to my hair. And I think, I don't know, I think it's fun. And I think it's like a broader metaphor for like just being willing to try anything once in life and just to give it just to give it a go. It's a great reflection of that. And I think if you haven't done it, you've got to do it. And when I did it last, I haven't dyed my hair for a while, but I dyed my hair black in like 2023.
而且这通常与我当时的情绪状态有关。但我就对自己的头发做过最疯狂、最愚蠢的事情。我想，我不知道，我觉得这很有趣。我觉得这就像是一个更广泛的隐喻，比方说在生活中愿意尝试任何事情一次，并且勇于去尝试。这是对此的一个极好的写照。我觉得如果你还没试过，你必须去试试。我上次做这个的时候，我已经有一段时间没染过头发了，但我大概在2023年把头发染成了黑色。
I'm blonde. It was a terrible decision. I really look terrible. Like I'm glad nobody said something, but I really, slash, I'm not glad. I'm still on the fence as to whether somebody should have pulled me aside and be like, this is not the color for you. But there's just like this unique beauty
我是金发。那是个糟糕的决定。我看起来真的很糟糕。虽然我庆幸当时没人说什么，但其实，或者说，我并不庆幸。我依然在纠结到底有没有人应该把我拉到一边对我说：这真的不是适合你的颜色。但那种感觉真的很独特
and like this unique feeling of looking back at those photos and being like, God, that was a terrible hair color. God, that was like an awful style. But I'm so glad. I'm so glad that I did it. I'm so glad that I gave it a shot and now when I have kids, hopefully I can be like, yeah, that was the year of this. So that was the year of that.
回看那些照片有一种独特的感觉，会觉得：天哪，那发色太糟糕了。天哪，那发型太逊了。但我很高兴。我很高兴我当时那么做了。我很高兴我尝试了一次，现在等我有了孩子，我希望我可以对他们说：对，那就是顶着这个发型的一年，或者那是顶着那个发型的一年。
And it just feels like hairstyle and that expression. And doing everything once is really tied to a good story. And it's tied to having good memories and having that kind of freeful openness to life that feels more and more worthwhile every single year. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
感觉发型和那种自我表达。把每件事都尝试一次，真的和一个好故事紧密相连。它和一个美好的回忆息息相关，并带着那种对生活自由开放的态度，这种态度让人觉得随着年岁增长，一年比一年更有价值。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the real. result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
来穿透那些主导养生行业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实是压力的真实结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是《TWO percent》，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do? little Kim. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理清我们是如何撑过那段日期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔探讨80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在节目里聊聊快克，真的，真的。但只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们还把爱滋病
on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
搬上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着积分榜看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，探讨关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。
on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一起亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的检测结果，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man. should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，《The Girlfriends》新一季，天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I'm realizing I'm actually going to finish on Lesson 27, which is one more than I promised to you, but I think this is my... hopeful takeaway from next year and the thing I'm currently learning, which is you don't have
收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。所以我意识到我实际上将在第 27 课结束，这比我向你承诺的多了一课，但我认为这是我……对明年的充满希望的收获，也是我目前正在学习的东西，那就是你不必
to suffer. And I know that that's really, it's very serious compared to our last lesson. But I think I just spent way too long thinking that how my brain was and how my life was was something I couldn't change. And the things I kept doing that were honestly self-sabotaging and that were causing me more pain than they should have and that were making me unhealthy and unhappy
去受苦。我知道这真的很严重，相比我们上一课。但我认为我花了太长时间认为我的大脑和我的生活是我无法改变的。我一直在做的事情，老实说是在自我破坏，这给我带来了比应有的更多的痛苦，让我变得不健康和不快乐
like I felt so imprisoned by them because that's how I'd always done things and I'm just realizing more and more like my life doesn't have to be bad. I don't have to suffer more than what I'm already going to naturally suffer just by being alive. And I have a choice in a lot of that.
就像我感到被它们深深禁锢一样，因为我一直以来都是这么做的，我越来越意识到，我的生活不必是糟糕的。我不需要承受比仅仅活着本身自然要承受的更多的痛苦。这里面很多事情我都有选择的权利。
I have a choice to go to therapy. I have a choice to get on medication. I have a choice to change my mindset, to have healthier habits. I have a choice to prioritize and deprioritize and deprioritize relationships and certain things in my life that are making my life harder. And I just felt for so long,
我有选择去接受心理治疗的权利。我有选择吃药的权利。我有选择改变心态、养成更健康习惯的权利。我有选择优先考虑以及降低优先级、降低关系和其他让我的生活变得更艰难的特定事情的权利。而且我很长一段时间都觉得，
like everything was just being handed to me, and I had to accept it. And maybe the biggest lesson from my 26th year, and hopefully again, my 27th year is that that is not true. And I can opt out of the circumstances and the things and the patterns of behavior that are making me suffer and that I don't want anymore. And it's hard and it's difficult and I definitely make a lot of excuses. But I'm at this point where I'm like, I want to live a life of ease.
仿佛一切都是被强加给我的，我只能接受。也许我 26 岁最大的教训，希望也是我 27 岁最大的教训，那就是事实并非如此。我可以选择退出那些让我痛苦、我不再想要的处境、事情和行为模式。这很难，很不容易，我肯定会找很多借口。但我现在到了这样一个阶段，我想过一种轻松的生活，
and I want to live a life of being as carefree and stress-free as possible, not as busy and successful and brash and loud as possible. And I just think that's been a huge, massive priority change, and maybe that's a lesson that you're learning as well, or that's a lesson that you need to hear. You don't have to suffer. You don't have to suffer more than life is going to make you suffer. Those are my 26, 27 lessons from
我想过一种尽可能无忧无虑、没有压力的生活，而不是尽可能忙碌、成功、浮夸和吵闹的生活。我只是觉得这是一个巨大、重大的优先级改变，也许这也是你正在学习的教训，或者这是你需要听到的教训。你不必受苦。你不需要承受生活强加给你的更多的痛苦。这些是我 26 岁时学到的
26 years. I hope that they've, I don't know, taught you something that you've related to them. Maybe it's validated an experience that you're having. If you're listening on Spotify and you have made it this far, I want to know. Give me a lesson that you have learned in the past year, past six months that wasn't on this list that you think other people could learn from. I feel like every year there's this new knowledge popping into my mind and I have definitely forgotten things that were important lessons, but I'd love to hear from you guys, and I'd love to hear your experience. Make sure that you are subscribed, following, wherever you are listening. If you were in the US or Canada, you can listen to this episode on Netflix. Actually, should I say,
26个教训。我希望它们，我不知道，教给你一些东西，让你能感同身受。也许它证实了你正在经历的经历。如果你在 Spotify 上收听并且听到了这里，我想知道。告诉我你在过去一年、过去六个月里学到的一个不在这个清单上、你认为其他人可以从中学习的教训。我觉得每年都有这种新的知识涌入我的脑海，我肯定忘记了一些重要的教训，但我很想听听你们的意见，我也很想听听你们的经历。确保你订阅并关注了你收听的平台。如果你在美国或加拿大，你可以在 Netflix 上收听这一集。其实，我应该说，
you can watch this episode on Netflix. I'm so used to saying, listen, but you can watch on Netflix, and I would love it if you did so. Make sure that you are as well following us on Instagram, and thank you for listening to this episode and for being a massive part of the last five years of my life. Almost all of my 20s. I don't know. I'm getting closer to 30. I have to decide if I'm going to do the psychology of your 30s or what's going to happen. So I guess time will tell.
你可以在 Netflix 上观看这一集。我习惯说收听，但你可以在 Netflix 上观看，如果你这样做了我会非常高兴。请务必在 Instagram 上关注我们，感谢你收听本期节目，并感谢你成为我过去五年生命中重要的一部分。几乎是我整个二十多岁。我不知道。我越来越接近 30 岁了。我得决定我是要研究“三十岁的心理学”还是会发生什么。所以我想时间会证明一切。
But be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is all. Also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
但请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会谈到。2%。这就是有电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app,
健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 i-Hart Radio 应用上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
苹果播客，或您获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。多少男人随身穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控怀有双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marincini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·马兰奇尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owen's, finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriend. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她们自己采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱法惩的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。这是 iHeart 播客，保证人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。